we are picky eaters and we're gonna play
would you rather I have very strong
conviction when it comes to my dining
experience and it's there's things I
like and there's things I don't like
I hate cilantro and I hate ginger and if
like the seasonings are off to me like
it'll just come right back out I don't
think there's gonna be a lot of good
choices ahead of for us so there's
probably just gonna be a lot of Tears
all right you ready yeah would you
rather eat beets or eat Brussels sprouts
easy for me Brussels sprouts clear
winner I'm all right with that oh that's
gross no not at all I never had a beet
never Willie to beat so I will eat the
green apatite well I won't do that I
don't believe in it I think I have to go
with beets assuming it's like a cooked
beat because they're kind of soft and a
little bit slimy
I would also beat Brussels sprouts
especially roasted Brussels sprouts
would you rather eat a spoonful of
mayonnaise or a spoonful of ketchup
that's just so gross I can't do either
either it grossed me out ketchup no
question I find mayonnaise revolting I
never wanted on my sandwiches ever
basically like french fries chicken
nuggets chicken tenders they're just
ketchup delivery like tools they're just
a way to get more ketchup into me so I'd
say a spoonful of ketchup I guess I'll
take your spoon a days because my
friggin love mayonnaise I guess I'll do
catch up over mayonnaise cuz man I do
like ranch though I love ranch right
yeah that's fans hands well ranch I'll
take a shot or ants right now would you
rather bite into a whole raw onion or a
bite into a whole Rob bell pepper oh
okay all right so I will literally throw
up if I eat onions one time it was high
school I had a sandwich and I said no
onions lunch lady and sure as hell
there's onions in there I threw up my
sandwich because of onions in that
sandwich what was the second option bell
peppers take that over onions any day of
the week I would rather eat the raw bell
pepper cuz it can be kind of sweet but
an onion like you I can't even like cut
that without crying so why would I eat
that I cannot eat bell peppers it
liquefies everything in my body
immediately I love it's a beautiful
thing where like I vomit in one
direction you vomit and the other one is
beautiful yeah yeah this was a perfect
storm bell pepper all the way like
onions are my
number one most hated thing can you just
bite into a knife I feel like it would
flake off on ya and they're like hard
and weird no would you rather eat a
spoonful of cottage cheese or a spoonful
of blue cheese I actually love cottage
cheese I also love cottage cheese Wow
yeah almost no one does I know I feel
like we're not as picky as we thought we
were cuz cheese blue cheese is kind of
gross I don't like to eat anything that
smells like feet I mean that's my
overall rule you don't like to eat
anything is your overall length yeah
would you rather eat sushi or eat raw
oysters eat sushi sushi all day every
newsie of course an oyster just looks
like a snot to me yes so I can't I'm the
big texture guy so I've had amazing
hoisters in the past like and they've
tasted okay but at the end of the day
it's that goo penis that I can't do I
don't love sushi but I'll eat it in a
pinch like if that's what everyone wants
to have I'm like okay all right would
you rather eat a bunch of broccoli or
eat a bunch of cilantro I think I'd have
to go with broccoli but it I mean is it
like cooked and covered in cheese I
think they mean raw broccoli we've
already solved that I ate a bunch of
broccoli last night cilantro is bad like
it is soap flavored paper it's garbage
yeah it's cilantro everyone who says
cilantro is good at lying they are I
also would go with broccoli I love
broccoli can't get enough of it it's
really easy it's how I build the
balanced diet so I'll have like a ten
piece of chicken wings and I'll just
handful broccoli would you rather eat
potato salad or egg salad
oh god I guess I would go with the egg
salad because I like my potatoes warm I
don't like eggs in that fashion that's
it's not like hot and cooked the only
hard-boiled egg oh god no I'm also gonna
go with egg egg salad I'm team potato
salad I guess I haven't seen potato
Sally had like maybe five bites of
either these ever would you rather eat a
bowl of peas or a bowl of beans peas I
love peas people don't like peas I
didn't know that that's new I love peas
I think I'm gonna go with beans cuz
they're the closest to meat that makes
sense I I'm also gonna go with beans are
there certain Chinese restaurants and
they put peas in there
fried rice and I always have to pick the
peas out I don't know
not a peep in ooh would you rather eat
pineapples on a pizza or eat olives on a
pizza all of Pizza all the way I love
olives Oh God
[Music]
man I love pineapple that being said I
don't think it belongs on a pizza
I rather bite into stupid pineapple
pizza versus an Olive pizzas interests I
hate olives we can't do it all so not a
fan of olives and that would ruin the
pizza for me just as much so I'm gonna
eat the pineapple on the pizza and maybe
secretly pick off the pineapple I need
that first I'm much more of a Hawaiian
pizza guy and I like the pineapple on it
you know what make a great pizza I think
it's like a vegetarian Hawaiian pizzas
if you just put pineapple and olives on
it I think that would be a good
combination disgusting
would you rather eat a spoonful of steak
tartare or a spoonful of caviar steak
tartare is great just raw like really
nice like cow me I think I would go with
the steak tartare what the hell is that
that's like basically just raw beef is
that all it is it's just like and then
you like sort of like mixed up with like
egg yolks and there's like capers and
some other stuff in there but like
that's it it's like that's delicious is
one of my favorite appetizers it like a
fancy dinner
okay so I will go over the caviar fish
eggs caviar is just like kind of briny
and gross anyways yeah I mean I've never
had either to be completely honest the
steak tartare it literally just made me
hungry right now so I feel like I would
go steak
it's like eating like raw ham like you
know when you buy hamburger meat from
the grocery store you're like now looks
pretty good as is well I know it looks
like brains
it looks pretty good okay
I'd be down with some steak tartare
mixer sounds great I think I'm not as
picky as I thought I was it seems like
your dislikes are very specific and you
could easily avoid them where mine seem
to be at every meal ever I mean yeah it
kind of shows the vote the the different
levels of picky eaters I guess because
we clash on many of things I liked
mayonnaise
you're wrong so these were our choices
but we're wondering what were in your
choices be in the comments
[Music]